نحن
نضطر ان نصمت الان طلب منا ان نصمت طيب
نشاهد الان يعني اعتقد انه هذا غطاء حتى
يعني لا تعلم يعني كيف وضع المصاب وللمصاب
حرمه يعني فلذلك
اعتقد انه غطاء حتى يبدو انهم يقتربون
كثيرا نحن
تم اخراج الطفله عائشه في هذه اللحظه
امامنا الان انا اشاهدها امامي اذا عائشه
الطفله عائشه تم اخراجها الان العربيه
ترصد لحظه انقاذ الطفله
عائشه انا اشاهدها معك غسان لكن هناك
التفاف كبير نعم صحيح اشاهدها الان تم
انقاذها ايضا خرجت بعد ثلاث ساعات من
محاولات الانقاذ خرجت وهي بصحه ربما ان
شاء الله في هذه كما تشاهد الان بعد سته
تحت الانقاض يعني وتم اخراج حتى
اخواتها من المكان اليك الصوره والصوت
ايضا لكن طلبوا منا ان نصمت يعني لكن
عائشه عائشه الان نايف الحمد لله عائشه
خرجت من فم الموت